okay so let's talk
like you know jackass and [ __ ] you know
when i say talk jackass i mean working
with the jackass director
jeff tremaine you developed that whole
bad trip movie
right like uh what's your uh what what's
your take on working with jeff germain i
mean for for us
you know making jackass movies i think
we would all agree
that he's a bad person you know putting
us in harm's way
you know putting us in harm's way he's
kind of an evil
sort of a dude you know he's like always
like
just looking for terrible things to
happen to us but but your experience is
probably a little bit different like
what's your take on the guy
yeah he is uh jeff is the
prank master he kind of knows exactly
like what will yield the highest results
and he kind of had to steer me in the
direction of
of um the marks are the stars
he's like you're you you think you think
i'm a comedian i'm going to get the
laugh in the scene but like
you're really you're engineering these
pranks to get the
the marks will have like the biggest
laughs in the screenings
and when we did those first couple test
screenings i was like
holy [ __ ] you're right we went into the
reshoots
engineering the uh
we're like fine tuning the pranks to get
the marks really riled up and invested
in the situation so he was really like
a mentor father figure to me throughout
the whole process because i was coming
just in from eric andre's show where we
we don't have to worry about story
none of the pranks make any [ __ ]
sense it's just like a nonsense
punk rock bang bang bang quarter hour
absurdist adult swim show but he was
very much like the story has to be
grounded and the character has to be
likable and relatable and
like the pranks have to function
like scenes so he he was really like
my obi-wan kenobi all through the
process
i appreciate i appreciate jeff he is he
i mean dude there's a reason why he's so
damn successful is because he's really
that talented
uh i hate to say it
but he said he told me that he gives it
to you guys way worse he's like
because he the more you guys are
tortured and punished the better the
editor is
it wasn't it wasn't quite the same thing
for our movie like jackass where
we're getting attacked by pythons and
bulls right
um getting getting tasered and [ __ ] like
that you know what i mean you do
you do pranks and stunts whereas we were
just doing pranks
when did tiffany haddish come into it
pretty much from the beginning of
production so the first day
we shot rel and i got a knife pulled out
on us we went to this barber shop in the
hood
with our dicks stuck in a chinese finger
trap and we went into the barber shop
and we were like hey man you got any
scissors get us out of this chinese
finger trap and this barber dude was
like oh hell no
and he started looking for his gun
couldn't find his gun grabbed his knife
we ran out me and rel are like joint
conjoined at the dick so he can barely
run
guys like [ __ ] chasing things with a
knife
i forget my safe word my safe words
popcorn so i'm looking at jeff and the
first ad and all that my director i'm
like
goosebumps goosebumps goosebumps my
adrenaline's so high i forget my own
safe word which is popcorn i start
shouting goosebumps
then i'm like i look at this our
security guard i go i'm sorry popcorn he
jumps out grabs a guy with a knife
hey man sorry you're on a hidden camera
show and the guy was with the knife was
like
oh man y'all are hilarious dude where's
this [ __ ] come out
and he's like you shouldn't be doing
these pranks in this neighborhood
he's like you're lucky i didn't bring my
gun to work damn so
because of that so to answer your
question because of that rel almost quit
he never did hang camera pranks before
he goes you guys are gonna get me
[ __ ] killed
i'm [ __ ] over this [ __ ] i got kids i
cannot be murdered
um i'm done he went home we thought we
lost rel he called tiffany haddish
because they're good friends he's like
i'm doing this [ __ ] eric andre movie
we had a knife pulled out on me this
guy's gonna get me killed tiffany starts
like dying laughing
five minutes later she calls me and she
goes yo you almost got real killed at
work today i go
yeah and then she goes yo i want to be
in your movie
all right and the girl that the woman
the woman that played
her um rel's sister in the movie just
dropped out
so i was like tiffany we actually have
an available there's only four cast
members and one just dropped out so like
it was just the universe providing us
with
one of the most talented comedians in
the world dude i've done comedy with
tiffany haddish i got footage of her
bringing me up on stage at the laugh
factory from 2006.
like i mean dude it was like your first
time on stage or second time or
something right right
it was uh i mean this is like way back
in the day and she's just always been so
supportive of me doing my stand-up and
giving me tags and and jokes i remember
i had this joke about
how i jack up so much that my dick
is like off to an angle because i've
been pushing it that way because i'm
right handed my dick goes that way
and i remember tiffany says uh she goes
oh when you do that i say my dick's like
a beyonce song
to the left to the left
[Laughter]
steve when you guys were filming did you
ever have safe words or things like that
yeah there's like oklahoma i forget when
um
when uh we electrocuted my balls what
the safe board was
i don't think it serves me to have a
safe word like uh
you ever used a safe word yeah when i
was when they were executing my balls
you actually said i said it too quick i
shouldn't have [ __ ] had a safe word
that's the problem with safe words they
ruined the bit
yeah i went back and watched a bunch of
old wild boys and i think that's [ __ ]
scarier than anything almost in jacka i
was like you're [ __ ] with
great white sharks yeah and gorillas and
silverback gorillas and gators you're
[ __ ] out of your
mind and bears how did you not get
[ __ ]
killed how did you not get injured by
those [ __ ] predators
there's a youtube video that uh we're
getting ready to put together
called times i could have died and
there's nothing
there's like not one jackass seen in it
it's
all wild yeah [ __ ]
what animal are you scared of the most
is there anyone in particular
i already could catch enough heat for
talking about myself the whole
podcast just happened no no i want to
know because jeff told me
what he thinks is the scariest animal he
said there's only one animal he'll never
work with again or something like that
oh it's like a scarce one i want to see
if it's the same one
he's probably going to say the wombat
right
no he said the walmart was gnarly but he
said chimpanzees
wow he's like he's like don't want to
[ __ ] with them what they rip
they rip off your genitals they rip out
your eyes they chew off your fingers and
then they continue to attack you oh the
chimpanzees
but he's not saying that based on any
experiences that we
had ourselves he's he's basing that on
like [ __ ] you read in the news
where they totally rip off your face and
your dick and eat it
and not necessarily like that old guy
brought brought a cake into the zoo
and the other the other chimps got
jealous and ripped off his dick and
[ __ ] tore his arms off yeah
i think that's what he was talking about
i don't remember us having an experience
with chimpanzees
what's with the wombat it was just the
angriest
one you know it's it went to marsupial
the wombat it was in uh uh i feel like
we were in tasmania
and it was just the [ __ ] angriest
most aggressive
just [ __ ] pissed off creature that we
ever encountered
isn't that a tasmanian devil didn't you
burn an entire village in south africa
now in the first day of shooting and
then
pontius like jumped in a hut and saved
two
german journalists or something and it
would be insane
i do remember when i oh i remember
i was confusing the stories but yeah it
was british
journalists we were in south africa we
burned down three cabins
and uh once we realized we couldn't put
it out we're breaking all these windows
and everything
screen get everybody get out we're all
like bloodied from smashing
windows and we did save the the lives of
the two
journalists and they did write an
article about us being heroes who saved
their lives
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude